cette terre était maudite notre famille
s'installa dans l'ouest sur une promesse
une promesse qui leur paraissaient
maintenant pour y ait plus de place pour
d'autres garçons dans cette famille
personne n'avait mis en garde mon frère
de ce qui pouvait arriver lorsque mon
rêve de son destin et ses lacs allison
wells est entré dans notre histoire
[Musique]
le voleur et la meurtrière allison wells
envoyé sa cabine au centre au paradis
vous apercevez cette femme
n'essayez pas de l'arrêter ça va bien
ils vont payer 20 mille dollars pour les
amener au mexique t'imagines si tu avais
autant d'argent pour doit réunir tous
les fermiers de la chercher il faut
qu'on y aille matraque
tu l'as trouvé pas vrai madame wells
c'est compliqué
tu sais la pire des choses qui lie avec
la mort le quidam
c'est d'être oublié
[Musique]
je suis pas vraiment à l'abri ici
cet endroit n'est sûr pour personne
[Musique]
je ne veux pas être une autre victime de
leurs mensonges
[Musique]